how's Gomez's beautiful today we're
gonna play hallow kick what what all
right well let's do with it the first
game is Hello Kitty marriage this is
quite ps-aguié kawaii ah God ah put it
back what the [ __ ] have I seen what what
about this ah we got it put it back
alright well I guess we'll just have to
live with Steve Buscemi being there
don't don't look don't look for too long
you could get eye AIDS actually let's
put that there makes me feel more
comfortable
he's kind of reaching for it he's like
hey hey yeah what's with that [ __ ]
haircut anyway he gets that there let me
go
is that glitter sound come from stop it
glitter sound so many outfits to choose
from that's a nice hat you got there
it's also very nice how great ah what'd
I say about the clothes this is a
cross-dressing
stop you will wear the stop hell is up
with this game and nakedness put it on
ah ah I can't I can't this game is too
much god damn Steve Buscemi next up is
Hello Kitty funny game I'm not kidding
but that's the actual title now it's
Kitty balls they were like it the [ __ ]
did you name our game no we can't call
it Kitty balls you [ __ ] idiot but
then what should we call it
hallo kitty funny game Kitty balls
alright can't wait to play Kitty balls
well [ __ ] me they lied about the title
oh god what the [ __ ] what is it
what the [ __ ] is recommended games
alright you know let's not get
distracted we are playing hallo kitty
Cedars [ __ ] a ride
no stay - right sit right accelerate
tour okay roar word ah
alright well [ __ ] pimp it out I guess
[ __ ] did it
slowly want to kill myself while playing
this this is great let's see if we can
do a backflip damn it
not even a city ride it's not even a
[ __ ] sit you know can we have a good
Hello Kitty game just one good one
Hello Kitty coloring choose a picture oh
god this game is racist hallo kitty
house makeover hello girls wanna come
sure we'll be there oh [ __ ] I gotta
clean all my [ __ ] up this happens every
time i snort cocaine i wake up and
there's a [ __ ] mess all right we
better clean it up I guess so you take
the pizza I put note oh you put in it
got it really a game about cleaning
that's that's the most fun we could have
well there's obviously no fun allowed
this place still looks like [ __ ] though
goddamnit what do you want from me so
this is a PlayStation 2 game for some
reason it's available online I'll play
as oh I like get up he's cute what the
[ __ ] have died monkey smoked alright
well this is fun suck my ass oh thanks
thanks for the Petrin icing tone [ __ ]
submit your score for a chance to win
500 bucks oh my [ __ ] god
yes I would like to hear about your
products submit I'm gonna get 500 pounds
well I'm sold I need to buy this game
how is this a Hello Kitty game I got it
I feel so perverted oh god that is too
much
you slaughtered a bunch of Hello kitties
you
horrible person I said that's [ __ ] it
goddamn it
all right we're playing Hello Kitty at
the doctor nightmares I'm gonna have
nightmares forever now that's great
those lips I'm sorry but those are
[ __ ] lips
don't worry hallo kitty this will only
hurt a lot squeeze those nips where do I
use this okay what did that oh god
please don't smile don't be sad I mean
oh she's crying
[ __ ] don't cry it's gonna be okay I
think I'm and said it is that is it door
all right well we better shrink that
giant set on your face get that nose
bleed out of the way that smile just
makes me so sad oh god
kitty I'm sorry that's right all better
why are you crying stop crying there we
go thank you good job doc why thank you
that was that was probably the best one
I played all right next up we have a
Hello Kitty online god damn it I have to
install it now it's on my computer I'm
sure it's more interesting than hallo
kitty cross-stitch at least uh hello
kitty online all right well sign up
please all right ready
apparently Sweden is not an acceptable
country anymore
yeah thanks Hello Kitty what is sweeter
Swaziland said except what they call
sweet I never ever seen this happen
before Wes wheat I'm like what do I do
okay Swaziland is that a big [ __ ] put
Swaziland in there but not Sweden I
don't even know what Swaziland was a
thing it is a thing it's in Africa well
[ __ ] me they got small board and John
main islands but not [ __ ] Sweden why
they need my email so they can send
important information about Hello Kitty
well I think anything of regarding Hello
Kitty is obviously important well I get
a Hello Kitty email address that's
awesome feel free to email me at ass at
Hello Kitty anytime all right finally we
can play
Jesus all right take your time take your
time all right any time now
any time now oh my god it worked
oh my god it's working I waited so long
for this no one is playing this is
anyone else a la Paz
wow that was Chet but don't worry we
have one more game that I legally bought
a Hello Kitty roller rescue oh my god
cutscene he I know oh Jesus Christ
see this is some quality Hello Kitty
[ __ ] I've seen them all but this is some
fine-ass Hello Kitty [ __ ]
oh yeah smack that ass what you don't
like all right well then guess I go talk
to Papa all right well let me let me
help you set up your game god damn it
pop I don't need you where's the roller
skating I specifically asked for a damn
roller skating
ohyeah idea Oh God who are you who are
these dirty peasants and why don't they
know the power of Sugoi God that looks
perverted hi oh my God look at his
ability
I [ __ ] [ __ ] up who the hell are you
why are you kidnapped what did the cage
go my mom I'm okay let's get out of here
mama I've decided to protect our town
all right I will do my best
ah ah so good well this has been a great
time with you bros to play some
allocated games I really felt like it
brought joy and happiness to my life and
I hope you feel the same way if you did
it leave a like it subscribe Humber
today and as always thank you for
watching stay awesome